- [Narrator] In Thailand,
there are over 40,000 Buddhist temples,
but there's only one that
looks quite like this.
Completed in 2004,
Wat Plai Laem is a collection
of temples and statues
located on Koh Samui, Thailand's
second largest island.
These are active temples
in a tranquil place
where quiet reflection is encouraged
and appropriate attire is a must.
One of the most eye-catching figures
is the statue of the Buddha,
which is 30 meters high
and painted in bright
red, white, and gold.
The main statue at Wat Plai Laem
is the Buddhist goddess of
compassion and mercy, Guan Yin.
Here, she's represented with 18 arms,
which shows her ability to help
many people in need at once.
The temple is surrounded by a
lake filled with hungry fish.
Visitors who make a donation to the temple
are given a bag of fish food.
People also buy fish and
turtles at the local food market
and release them into the lake.
Buddhists consider it an
act of spiritual merit,
and the fish and turtles do, too.